yeah okay
right good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the signature ceremony of the
financial framework partnership
agreement which will help boost joint
investment in infrastructure projects in
Africa the financial framework
partnership Arrangement will be signed
by the president of the European
commission Ula wonderlan and the
president of the African Development
Bank Dr akinomi adeso will now witness
the signing of the financial framework
partnership Arrangement please
proceed now the right
side you got a different kind than me
yes you know that one started when I was
Minister in Nigeria and all the schs
have to sign oh really yes president
Side
Green
so
change
[Applause]
okay good this Rings us to the end of
the ceremony thank you very much for
having thank you very much yes thank
Youk you thank you
all thank
[Music]
you